In space, no one can hear you complain…
about that leaky faucet.
Also, you definitely can't call a plumber,
so how do things get fixed?
Hey tinkerers, Trace here for DNews.
Space is only 62 miles away, but it's taken
countless hours of engineering and science
throughout history to get us there.
But there's one thing all machines do, and
that is fail.
They will eventually, and inevitably fail.
A mechanical failure is always an annoyance,
but when it happens in space, that is all
compounded, and even little things can become
huge challenges.
If anything goes wrong, astronauts are on
their own, and as Astronaut Don Pettit told
DNews, Mission Control can think of 80 percent
of things, but even they can't cover all of
it, and when that happens -- according to
Pettit -- you need to become MacGyver.
*sing theme!*
As the ISS is pretty much like going into
the wilderness, in the most awesome science-future
way possible, Astronauts need to be self-sufficient
and creative thinkers -- which is part of
the reason they go through years of rigorous
training in medical, engineering, flight,
and so on.
So when things DO break, how do they repair
them…
unconventionally.
In 2006, astronauts on the ISS were testing
experimental heat shield gel by spreading
it on test surfaces… but they needed to
smooth it out.
Doing that in space proved difficult, so...
they used spatulas from the kitchen.
Yep, regular old spatulas.
On Jan 15, 2003 -- Don Pettit and Ken Bowersox
suited up for an EVA to clean debris off the
outside of the docking port, so they could
safely attach a service module and move cargo
into the station.
The problem was, sandblasting that had been
going on down on the launchpad in the days
before the shuttle launched, and had contaminated
the cargo with sand.
The shuttle brought sand with it to space.
Somehow that sand got caught in the lubricant
on the outer hatch -- which would have compromised
docking.
I interviewed astronaut Don Pettit, and he
said he used wire (not unlike a coat hanger)
and a t-shirt to wipe the sand off so they
could get a better seal.
True story!
Another major repair device?
Duct tape -- used on Skylab to help astronauts
boots lock in to the floor, and also a specialized
Klaxon tape -- sort of like reflective electrical
tape.
During Gemini-Titan 4 astronaut Ed White performed
the first EVA -- or spacewalk -- ever.
And he wrapped his two tethers with Klaxon
tape to keep them neat and untangled.
Obviously these are just a few examples, but
being a MacGyver is part of the astronaut
mentality.
As Pettit put it, "We've got the best experts
on the ground…and spaceflight is the ultimate
team sport."
Astronauts go through intensive training,
they're members of NASA's astronaut corps,
and the requirements are "superior academic
qualifications," but also a certain temperament.
According to a NASA representative, astronauts
need to be cool in "risky" and "isolated environments,"
they're likely to be gregarious and someone
who'd be considered a "good neighbor," but
Pettit told me, you need to be a tinkerer
too, because quote, "If you tinker on earth,
you're going to be good at tinkering on orbit."
Astronauts are the kind of people that when
something breaks, they'll figure out how it
works, and then how to fix it in microgravity
-- with whatever they have around.
Since NASA ended the space shuttle program
in 2011, the International Space Station is
even more out on a limb.
Without the large shuttle to bring replacement
"boxes," as Pettit called them, they're forced
to repair things that were never meant to
be repaired in space.
Like Pettit did with the on-board refrigerator
during one of his missions.
The ISS is slated to fly until 2024 -- another
8 years -- and things are aging.
Astronauts are testing 3D printing technology
on orbit to make some parts but there will
always be someone MacGyvering and jury-rigging
to survive in the final frontier.
If you're thinking, why bother?
Leave it be, we don't need the ISS!
Lemme try and convince you, with THIS video
about why the ISS even matters at all.
One time, I lowered a lead weight with sticky
tape on a fishing line into the space between
the drywall and outer wall 15 feet to recover
a USB adapter it was so awesome.
What's your proudest MacGyver story -- do
you even know who Richard Dean Anderson IS?!
GAHD!!!